we are not allowed to believe that there
are
uh two sexes and that you know
right their behavioral manifestation we
are not allowed to believe that we are
understood to be bad people if we do
yeah i i a little self-conscious about
saying this but i think that that uh my
former um co-author and i were the first
people to come up with that idea of
wokism as a religion in 2014 an essay we
published in all think uh privileges the
original sin we talked about this is a
new religion
but you see
so this is the explanatory mechanism for
why
media literally every institution you
can think of has been captured
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i'm of course dr brett weinstein
i am sitting with
professor in exile peter bogosian peter
bogosian welcome to dark horse thanks
brother i should alert the audience that
you are co-author of the very successful
book how to have impossible
conversations you are founding faculty
at the university of austin correct uh
you are the author of articles in
scientific american new york times wall
street journal new republic many many
different places
people will be familiar with you of
course from the what has come to be
called the so-called squared uh hoax or
whatever the proper return instead of
even studies affair those being one of
the same
in any case welcome to dark horse thank
you i appreciate appreciate being here
um it's overdue that you're here you and
i are both portlanders we are also
friends and uh this should have happened
long ago
i should probably tell people who are
going to be scratching their hands about
why you're sitting in the chair i
usually sit in oh yes that's good yeah
that's good well i'm deaf in this ear
and so if i sat there i would hear
almost nothing you had to say to me so
is it is it i mean let's just put it
this way this is a feature potentially
because if i start saying things that
offend you then you can just switch over
that's right that's right that's how
that's how you know that i like you when
i talk to you because like right you
want to be you want to be hearing what i
have to say i actually woke up one day
just totally out of the blue at 42 and i
went to the interest story i went to the
ohsu over here
and the head of the ear nose and throat
division came to this really old older
guy with gravitas and he said to me
uh he looked and he looked in my ear and
it had the this view screen up there he
said i i'm afraid i have really bad news
for you and i just freaked out i'm like
oh my god this is like some brain
aneurysm i'm gonna die or something and
he said to me you have sudden idiopathic
unilateral hearing loss so sudden
idiopathic no non-cause unilateral one
hearing loss
and it took me a second to comprehend
that and then he said to me you're never
gonna hear out of that ear again and it
was i was awash in relief because i
thought he told me i was gonna die
i thought he told me like i had some
brain
right something yeah you know it sounds
bad it is bad but it's not bad in a
things are much worse than you know
because obviously you had realized you
weren't hearing that right and i
actually breathed a sigh of relief when
you told me anyway so that's why i'm
sitting on this side yeah well that's
interesting it actually does raise a
question about whether or not
the
the army of the woke has a metaphorical
version of this disease where they can't
hear anything to the right of them
yeah if you over
overlay a moral
a template on that and so
they believe anything to the right of
them if that stephen pinker's the left
pole when you're on the left pole
everyone looks to the right but they
overlay a moral
template on that and so they think that
they're better people because they don't
listen or because they walk out or
because they shout you down that gives
them not just social status but moral
standing well that's actually of course
the literal definition
of the word prejudice to pre-judge they
have prejudged everything on a basis um
that where they are is correct they do
nothing to check this and therefore
anything that challenges them
is uh is wrong by definition our first
sponsor for this episode is eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer as we
discuss in the sleep chapter of hunter
gatherer's guide intelligent life that
found its way to earth might be
surprised by a lot of what it found on
our planet but likely not by the fact of
sleep or dreams
sleep is necessary without good sleep we
are destined to be unhealthy and
unproductive yet more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and
temperature is one of the main reasons
it is well known that individuals and
couples who sleep together often have
different optimal sleep temperatures
eight sleep allows fine-tuned
temperature regulation for both people
having a cool room and a warm bed is a
luxury that eight sleep makes easy to
obtain
or a warm room with a cool bed you make
the choice without driving your partner
crazy
the pod pro cover by eight sleep is the
most advanced solution on the market for
thermal regulation
you can add the cover to any mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 yikes
the temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages biometrics and bedroom
temperature reacting dynamically to
create the optimal sleeping environment
eight sleep users fall asleep up to 32
percent faster reduce sleep
interruptions by 40 percent and get more
restful sleep overall and with 30
percent more deep restorative sleep on
average they are likely to benefit from
faster physical recovery improved
hormone regulation and increased mental
clarity
finally the alarm feature which will
wake you with a temperature change and
or slight chest level vibrations
is so much gentler than any standard
alarm heather and i were both a little
skeptical and now totally sold we are
surprised by how much we appreciate this
bed
go to aidsleep.com darkhorse to check
out the pod pro cover and save 150 bucks
at checkout eight sleep ships to the usa
canada and the uk that's eightsleep.com
darkhorse
you have a right to bear arms but not to
bare feet why is that
well whatever the reason our second
sponsor aims to change it
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of feet the people at vivo barefoot have
a better idea
vivo barefoot are shoes made to free
your feet and they're a revelation
here at dark horse we love these shoes
they are beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from surfaces you're walking on
is amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution
humans evolve to walk move and run
barefoot
but modern shoes that are overly
cushioned and strangely shaped have
negatively impacted foot function and
are contributing to a health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by
sixty percent in a matter of months just
by walking around in them
and the number of people wearing vevo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
vevo barefoot has a great range of
footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear
there are certified b corp pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild on it
go to vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive twenty
percent offer
additionally all new customers get a
100-day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do
that's v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse
it is an astonishing degree of arrogance
it is an astonishing degree of
unshakable moral certitude
of hubris
and and also embedded in that it's as if
it's not as if you've
taken the time to do the intellectual
work in a diligent rigorous study of the
history of western intellectual thought
or even you know i guess i see your
bookshelf over here you know suicide or
the western it's not as if they've
looked at pieces and looked at articles
that disagree with their thoughts and
then come up with the best reason then
reason no there's none of that there's
no intellectual it's in
a complete withdrawal from any
in which they would not do with almost
anything else of significant consequence
well it's a little bit like they have
been intellectually arrested in their
development before the acquisition of
nuance
right it's like
you know yeah that's a good many of us
have
strong beliefs about the way things work
but we're aware that not all of the
evidence goes in that direction that you
know that the universe is complex and
until you develop that recognition
things look very black and white and
really the question is
are they capable of growing out of it
okay so we need one more piece to that
before we talk about the other piece is
that they gain
their ideas are
they're rewarded for those ideas through
the institutions they're rewarded
through the ideas when they see these
ideas percolate in various media outlets
in the academy
especially and so they're receiving the
sanctuary and imprimatur and they go
through these ideal ideas it's basically
these colleges and now particularly
humanities are ideology mills and so
they receive training it's ideology they
believe these there's bodies of
literature so for them their certitude
derives at least in part because they
believe
that it's
been gained through a legitimate process
from people who have done the
intellectual work that they themselves
have not done
right and it
it goes to a point that heather and i
make it's one of our core educational
points is that you cannot trust an
education that is based entirely on
things that are mediated through a
social channel in other words correct if
the fact that the person at the front of
the room thinks that what you've said is
very clever doesn't mean that it is or
it isn't and so it's very important that
everybody
engage systems that are capable of
telling you when your thinking isn't any
good you know if you're a carpenter and
you're making a dovetail joint and you
think it should work this way right and
then you attempt it and it doesn't fit
nobody has to tell you that didn't work
and you need to change it right another
way to think about that is a corrective
mechanism you need some way to correct
your cognitions to align them with
reality and there are there's a limit
there's so many things you can do in the
physical domain
like carpentry you can just empirically
you could just start cutting up joints
and sticking man but in the cognitive
domain you can do that linguistically
through a dialectic
so you can do that in conversation with
others
provided that those people actually
as opposed to just
you know being your devil's advocate
which is
an interesting history of the phrase as
well from the from the catholic church
but
what is needed is exactly the tools that
are needed are exactly the things that
the woke absent themselves from being in
a dialectic of people who disagree with
you and developing arguments so that you
can
accurately assess how confident you
should be in a belief based upon the
reason and evidence you have for that
belief right it's uh
it's basically a methodological
confirmation bias were they to confront
evidence
that runs counter to their belief system
that would be harder to maintain it and
you know as you started uh you pointed
out that basically the institutions are
rewarding people for wrong thinking
correct right for thinking incorrect
things and
that results in the mind basically
adapting itself to this
niche right the niche is here are some
wrong things that we want you to believe
by the time you leave this institution
and if you challenge them because they
are wrong you will be penalized you will
come out worse and if you accept them
and in fact advance them then you will
do better and so it is impossible for a
compliant mind to recognize that it is
being sort of lured into
fitting a container that is itself a
fiction so i want to talk about some of
those things oppression variables uh
systemic racism equity
but the piece of this we haven't talked
about it's on the other side as well
it's from the professor
professoria professors see these
administrators see this so the whole
system is in a sense
geared
to misalign people's
beliefs with reality it's been
ideologically captured they've created
mechanisms testing and sent they've
incentivized
you
or students believing certain things
for even the very shift from
education as a truth-seeking institution
educate to lead out of
to education being to remediate or
alleviate oppression from polyphrase
pedagogy of the oppressed even the very
way that we think about the structure of
our institutions in their newest star
has changed
right and any questioning of that is
blasphemy by the way right as uh as
jonathan height points out right or the
two laws of the university right yeah
you can't have a social justice
university and a truth it's impossible
it's one or the other yeah
that's the other thing there there are
so many things you you can't have you
you can't have equity and equality you
can't have but here's the thing when you
opt out of the law of non-contradiction
none of those things are a problem
explain that well when you just say you
know i'm not buying into this notion
that things that i say can't contradict
itself because i don't buy into this
idea that there's an objective reality
like my subjective experience my
standpoint epistemology that is the only
thing that matters and so
if something is a contradiction that's
just a contradiction to you
it's not something that i have to be
legitimately or concerned about or
concerned about in any way at all so you
so they just
they're not only the rules of discourse
it's just the rules of thinking
themselves they've absences absented
themselves from well i suspect that this
is also in its own way a failure of
development in the sense that
a child a very young child does not
necessarily have a sense of where they
are in time right what the relationship
of yesterday is to today is to tomorrow
and if you do an instantaneous measure
this thing i am saying feels very right
at this moment the fact that it
contradicts something i said 10 minutes
ago only matters if i believe in a kind
of consistency between 10 minutes ago
and now but if i'm only holding myself
accountable for the thing that's
emerging from my mouth in this instant
right then it isn't such a problem and i
would argue yeah heather and i
noticed when we were when we were
professors
that there was
a
an odd contradiction between what the
faculty thought of each other and what
the students apparently took away from
those faculty so if you gather the
faculty in a room right
the faculty vehemently disagreed with
each other on fundamental issues there
was no world view that they all embraced
that could be described in which there
were you know maybe disagreements at the
fringe there were fundamental
disagreements between from one part
department to the next but when the
students
went from one class to the next they did
not treat what they learned two hours
ago as if it had to reconcile with what
they're learning right now they treated
everything all a cart right everything
was you know basically with respect to
this professor am i making sense and so
it was clear that the the students were
playing a game right that they were not
learned they did not even in their own
minds imagine that they were learning
about the universe and some large story
that humanity has figured out that's a
grand narrative
right right it's a granter what they
were doing was learning to please the
person at the front of the room and it
was very hard when we were teaching
to break them of this habit because in
general the professors would punish them
for
trying to reconcile things that they had
learned in different courses right the
professors wanted the installation of
presenting their own story and not
having a challenge come back so that's
releasing a number of levels one is that
you create a culture in which people
don't speak honestly and openly
so you you don't know what anybody else
believes you just know what their verbal
behavior is
so the cultural aspect i would even go
beyond that and say that you
create a culture in which
everybody operating in that is
pretending to know something they don't
know
yes because they yeah i mean if
so this is something i've been thinking
about for years now
[Music]
when when
okay so this is a this is a big thing
because
it's coupled with systems to what extent
do people have to understand arguments
against their position
before they can have adequate confidence
to justify
their belief in a claim
well i would argue it depends very much
on the nature of what is being asserted
and one of the most difficult logical
skills is understanding
to what degree
this part of an argument is contingent
on this part of the argument in other
words just simply knowing that all the
pieces aren't true in an argument
doesn't tell you what the consequence of
the falseness of this piece is right
okay so this is also something to
piggyback off of that that i've been
thinking about a long time when you look
at
the really canonical documents about
critical thinking so really the deep
dive stuff
the american philosophical association
has this piece i talk about all the time
it's wonderful it's the it's called the
delphi report
and basically they say the critical
thinking is a skill set and a
disposition
but what's been a main thrust of my work
is if you have the skill set
but don't have the disposition you'll
drive yourself further into delusion
because you you you look in your
epistemic landscape you'll look for
things that confirm what you already
believe
so you have to have the attitudinal
disposition certain attitudes being
trustful of reason and willing to revise
your belief would be in my opinion the
top two but if
but we don't really teach the attitude
in fact we almost punish the attitude
and here is the uh the ultimate case
yeah right
in science
you have to have
what i would say is a perverse
disposition right we are all
born
wanting
to be right about things right it's much
more pleasant to be right about things
than to be wrong to be good at science
you have to take a belief that you are
actually rooting for let's say you come
up with some clever hypothesis yeah you
can't help but want it to be right right
but you have to work hard to prove it's
wrong
yeah and that is so it's a it's a
difficult
counter-intuitive kind of skill yeah and
here's the problem yeah what we have
done to the funding of science has
caused scientists to become advocates
for themselves and when you
train them to be advocates when you're
constantly
forcing because they won't get grants if
right they have to sell their their
proposal to the granting agencies to you
know their departments and the point is
it turns them into salesmen and they
become absolutely incapable of
scientific thinking yet as you point out
they have all the tools right i mean in
some cases they literally have the tools
they have very fancy scientific uh you
know uh machinery
and they have the language so they sound
like scientists they look like
scientists they function in a way like
scientists but the mindset is completely
reversed and what it results in is
very compelling wrong narratives
delivered by people who have the
authority that you know that causes
other people to simply say well what
would i know yeah i published a piece a
piece that was
an adjunct to that idea that talks about
when very smart people get together
was that from your bike yes from our
bike accident
when very smart people get together
people who are better at rationalizing
you know coming up with good reasons for
bad conclusions in groups you're better
at that and so
when groups of smart people to get
together they're better at rationalizing
in other words coming up with good
reasons for bad conclusions and that's
why you see entire departments um
think you know
there's a line in that the gatekeepers
of reason have fallen talking about
philosophers so they just basically
promote the dominant moral orthodoxy
they promote these narratives to which
there's really not only is there no
evidence at this point but we actually
know for example trigger warnings safe
spaces microaggressions there's a large
a growing body of evidence against that
yeah
so we we have
it it's it's a
it's a explains a kind of
mechanism a social mechanism for how
culture is created
and how it
uh organizations particularly academic
organizations become ideologically
captured and we've you've lived it i've
lived it
right and you know and then the
following dynamic emerges right
you see it
eventually
you call it out right because what else
can you do
and then the point is wait wait i'm
sorry to interrupt you you see it
you ask about it
right you politely ask about it that
doesn't go so well yeah that that
doesn't go well you cut and
maybe we share this then then you kind
of up it a little bit and say
okay so first you ask to understand then
you ask for evidence and that goes even
worse
yes and in fact it is a cryptic
negotiation right the institution is
constantly in myriad ways asking you
what would it take for you to just shut
the [ __ ] up about this and if the answer
is well no actually yeah that is
evidence that's what it would take yeah
you'd have to you'd have to show that
there was some reason to think you were
right and short of that
the whole reason i'm here yeah is to
call out bad thinking like that but then
the point is okay
so you are driven out
which then
reinforces the
false consensus right when those who
disagree with it
are driven out what you're left with is
the consensus and i forget who
um who described it this way but it is
analogous to evaporative cooling right
that effectively what this does is
concentrates the group thinking
mentality because anybody who shows any
inclination to challenge it
leaves and that leaves the people who
are least likely to challenge it yeah
that that leaves them more confident
in their assertions they calibrate their
confidence up in their beliefs and then
they're all bouncing it back we try and
then the incentivization structure for
the uh promotion and tenure basket
for example and i see what happened uh
with bruce gilley when he's published so
much stuff in his department shares
constantly telling him he's not
publishing enough i mean it's just it's
crazy i mean it's like it's like crazy
it's literally crazy the whole thing i
mean you know i mean
so okay so we have we have multiple
layers of craziness we have the people
who participate in the systems and those
systems have the imprimatur of social
legitimacy through the academy
uh
portland state being my former employer
and then you have the kind of the foot
soldiers of the ideology and i think
that these individuals share certain
characteristics i wrote put a tweet on
this and people lost their [ __ ] minds
can i swim in their apartment oh please
they lost their [ __ ] minds
and it was
about poor body habitus of people who
i can't remember the exact quotation but
people who participate in certain world
views i mean you see it with neo-nazis
right
their ideology manifests in their bodies
he's
grossly overweight or they're just like
uber steroided muscular people so you
have a level of people who have some
kind of undiagnosed low-level mental
condition who
believe that they should be more
successful they're not they blame the
system they get together with other
people who believe this thing and then
they go to the academies or
they even go to teacher training
programs it's like those who can't do
teach those who can't teach teach jim
woody allen's favorite thing like
they they they become teachers
and so we have a kind of
um western civilization has seen itself
in portland we don't need to
go anywhere
we've seen
ongoing continuous riots of people
and we know who these people are we know
these people are basically dyspeptic
malcontents under accomplished
raging at the system
they've told us they can't be governed
they put it on signs right and
right and and the the offering of all of
this and that's the other thing that's
infu not even if it used to be
infuriating to me but now it's just
frustrating is the link between the
academy and the spill out to the academy
the link between what people learn and
how people get caught in the orbit of
the ideology even if they're not true
believers of every tenant or every
belief
and then how that gives cover for the
radicals
all right so here here's the place where
this gets strange for me
i have
always been
pretty bold about
sharing my beliefs even if i knew that
they were out of phase with the room i
was in
right that's always been a positive
thing it's not always positive in the
moment right it does cause issues but um
but the net effect of it has been
positive
increasingly as the world has gone crazy
and embraced
we fear nonsense right in portland here
most people if you ask them what they
believed would you know check lots and
lots of boxes that would cause your and
my blood pressure to rise
but here's the funny thing
when i confess
my doubts right if i'm having an
interaction and we're at the place in
the interaction where i'm supposed to
say the usual things about embracing
equity and yeah you know gender
diversity or whatever it is that i'm
supposed to say i never say it
and i always say well actually um i'm
concerned that that is a very wrong
perspective and i explained something of
what i see i don't say very much but i
say enough that somebody can register
that i am not party to that set of
beliefs
i essentially never get challenged what
i get is relief from the person on the
other side and then yeah i'm not on
board with that either in fact and then
they pick up the ball and so i have the
sense that what's going on is you have a
lot of people who think everybody else
is believing this thing and they better
go along with it but the slightest
indication that they are in the presence
of somebody who can handle a different
perspective right and they want to talk
about it they're just itching to do so
so
right so that's that's the culture of
pretending that i talked about and i
think it was breaking the spell dennett
talks about the antenna talks about that
a little bit but
we've created a culture in which people
are pretending
to know things they don't know and
pretending to believe things that they
couldn't possibly believe possibly
right
men can become women just by saying so
enough that we should send them to a
women's prison even if they're they're
being sent for and they're sexist
they're intact so shall we say right
they're into haven't had bottom surgery
capable of committing rape right um
guilty of uh a sexual crime right we
should still take them at their worst
trans women or women period no matter
what and his custody in every
conversation i have to say this i'm sure
this i don't wait are we declaring
pronouns no no okay i support the right
of anybody over 18 to transition i
support to complete them to be live
fulfilling happy lives et cetera et
cetera et cetera this is not about that
yep no absolutely look if you're really
in a situation where you're going to be
happier and more fulfilled saying you
know what
uh for whatever reason my body is out of
phase with with my mind and i'm making
this transition i i actively support
i don't support pretending that that is
more common than it is and
going after people too young
to have a nuanced enough mindset
right people who are frankly
rightly feeling out of place right if
every young person is feeling out of
place because civilization isn't working
and then you say hey you know why you're
feeling out of place were you born in
the wrong body right right abigail
schroeder talks about that irreversible
damage it's the clustering effect you
see the clustering effect and the point
is it is creating
a
artificial
momentary sense of relief that is going
to be followed for most of these folks
with a lifetime of regret right and
that's the thing that's
so horrific about this once this
ideology falls into disrepute you'll
repute
who in their right mind we're going to
see epic gas lighting who
literally nobody is going to say you
know what i was in favor of mutilating
the generals of children experimentally
yeah nobody nobody's going to say
they're all going to pretend they were
on the other side yeah you were on the
other side all right i never said that i
never believed that they'd be epic
gaslighting but that gets back to what
we talked about before
of
speaking openly speaking honestly and
like you said you know some people are
just not going to like you well [ __ ]
them you know i mean
yeah yeah it's so also i wanna so that's
it brings us to something so
if i said something
publicly or what have you that you
didn't like
you would and now i'm speaking for you
you would tell me yeah yeah and if you
said something well that that first of
all i would tell you privately you would
i would expect you to tell me privately
i wouldn't expect you to progression to
you know well it depends if you said
something that mattered publicly i would
feel entitled to respond publicly
because the point is you're having a
public discussion about something it
wouldn't be personal okay well wait a
second wait a second
wouldn't it be better for you to tell me
privately and then for me to
perhaps reconsider or readjust my
beliefs publicly so that it comes from
me as opposed to the social
it depends it depends you know if you
say
um
as
many have
that
religion is a mental disorder right it's
a mind virus right which i think i have
said something very similar to that
wouldn't surprise me in light of the
fact that that was considered
sophisticated in new atheist circles
i don't see any reason that i shouldn't
say here's why that can't be right and
make an argument yeah okay so i guess it
depends on the claim i i guess it
depends on what the claim is
i i would think so if someone put it on
myself so if you said something
that i thought was way out of line
i would tell you privately i don't think
it is way out of line to say religion is
a mental disorder i think it is
factually incorrect it is logically
untenable right so saying something i
guess it depends on if that's that's the
question if i think if i think you
overstep yeah then yes i would say
privately look here here's the problem i
have with what you said but if you're
taking an analytical position publicly i
don't see any reason i shouldn't
analytically point out why
you may be right and i may be wrong
right and and that's the critical
thinking piece again i would
wow how much how much more would you
respect me if i reflected on i thought
about and said you know what i had this
opinion brad or whoever said something
to me i looked it up for myself i looked
up the best available
arguments and evidence from people on
the other side
i don't have sufficient evidence i've
thought about it i've changed my mind
boom well there are two failure modes so
i see this as an important part of being
an honorable uh interlocutor yeah
interlocutor
one
people do respect you for reversing your
position on the basis of evidence or a
persuasive argument they it in fact
enhances your credibility with people
unless you do it too often because what
it indicates is that you're not putting
in the work on the front end trying to
be right so you're wrong a lot and you
reverse your position that makes you not
very credible
so the ideal thing is to do your
homework on the front end try not to
make arguments that are substantially
incorrect and when you do make an
argument that's substantially incorrect
or miss a piece of evidence or
misinterpreted
get on the right side of it do it
forthrightly explained how you made your
error why you changed your mind and then
the point is that's about the best you
can do because you know especially on
complex topics nobody is going to avoid
being wrong all the time
so
isn't it better
to have a friend
like that
who who has those that's a disposition
yeah yeah isn't it better to have to
develop and cultivate a friendship with
someone who has those dispositions than
with someone who does not i'd i would go
further it's impossible
you don't want that as much as you may
in principle like somebody who can't do
that
it's too dangerous and too costly right
the fact is friendships are about
something real right friendships may be
pleasant and aesthetically nice when
times are good but the point is a real
friend is somebody who's there when
times aren't good and what you can't
afford is somebody who is going to talk
themselves into uh
a nonsense position because it's
convenient to do so and a real friend is
also someone you know what they mean
when they're honest with you they're
forthright with you and they're telling
you something because it's they believe
even if they're incorrect that it's in
your interest to hear it
right and if you surround yourself by
people who don't do that
not only aristotle writes about this not
only we you never be fulfilled in your
life
you know those
forms of friendship
you know virtue friendships
if you don't have that you're really
leading a life bereft of i mean you
might have meaning but bereft of any
potential that you could ultimately have
well i think actually the pandemic
revealed this in spades
that there you know most people
especially young people who have somehow
oddly gotten over the idea that they're
supposed to partner with somebody right
who sort of see that as unnecessary or
antiquated or something that people got
caught
without anybody whose opinion they could
actually trust and what they heard was
the party line coming from every
person you had no idea why anybody was
saying those things whether they really
believed yeah they believed it deeply so
i think i think
part of that confusion comes from a
whole constellation of factors
uh less so young people and more so um
older people the older people i think
it's we older people just don't trust
our institutions anymore i've been
texting tweeting about this for
years now it's
a crisis of legitimacy harbor moss talks
about it we don't trust our institutions
because our institutions
are not worth our trust
younger people
often conflate platform size with
something to say just because someone
has a large platform in whatever i just
had a podcast with a really nice guy he
had a lot of
um
twitter subscribers
first time i ever talked to him
i really enjoyed our conversation
tremendously but just because someone
has a large platform that doesn't mean
anything nothing follows from that other
than they have a large platform right
well you know i i think that there are
certain
rubrics you can use to figure out um
whose critique is worth paying attention
to and somebody who has accomplished
something
their critique means a lot more than
someone who hasn't or maybe even can't
accomplish something also somebody with
predictive power
that second thing i'm glad i i i didn't
interrupt you if you think you're smart
make a prediction make a prediction make
a prediction right
um the the first now i'm caught up on
predictions what was the first thing you
said to that um somebody who has
accomplished something yeah so i've been
thinking about tom nicholls rights about
a death of expertise we have a death of
expertise you mentioned the pandemic we
would have been so much better off in
the beginning if people said look we
don't know we really don't know yet
that's literally all they had to say
we're doing our best
we don't know
they did
but the problem is two things happened
one
lots of us said we don't know let's
figure out what we can and the natural
process whereby a model of the virus a
model of the epidemic a model of
people's behavior began to emerge that
thing was actually doing beautifully
but
handed down from on high was then a set
of prescriptions where we were told what
the virus was where it came from how it
behaved what we needed to do and all of
it was wrong yeah so so
you know i'm always amazed when people
ask me about this like what do you think
about i mean how the [ __ ] do i know i
have no
not only
do i have nothing substantive to add i
have in high school no offense but i
haven't had a high school biology class
since i was in high school and high
school was my last point yeah
interactive biology i have no no i have
no so like
nobody should listen to me no wrong
really why tell me why anybody should
listen to me well it's not that they
should listen to you as an authority on
the biology but let's just say
we were all told that the covet vaccines
were highly effective and that what was
necessary in order to control the
disease was our compliance
right
correct
correct i wouldn't use the word
compliance but that we all should we all
accepted we could all accept and i would
say in
given yeah a high quality vaccine that
was safe enough that yeah we should all
do our part and get it but
anybody and i got it right away i got it
for a multitude of reasons i i told you
i have crohn's disease it's an
autoimmune disease so i got it right
away and boosted etc right well maybe
we'll come back to what happened to you
okay nonetheless my point would be
if you're told if you are assured this
vaccine is very effective at preventing
people from contracting and transmitting
covid and then
you find out two months later well it's
not very effective at preventing people
from contracting
or transmitting covet and then it turns
out it's not effective at all and it
turns out places where essentially
everyone took it haven't controlled the
virus and now we have a wave of the
virus that is running rampant through
the vaccinated population then the
answer is well
i don't know anything about how
i'm now not speaking for me i'm speaking
for a lay person but i don't know
anything about how viruses function or
how vaccines create immunity but i can
tell that what i was told yeah didn't
turn out to be right and i can tell that
the people who i was told were
distributing misinformation turned out
to be much more predictive right that is
something anybody can see
yeah so i guess in that situation
and i'm even hesitant to have these
conversations because i know so little
about
i don't want to even say the biology the
medical aspect the epidemiological
aspect of it
um
yeah i think
i think we can say
that if we were told something and it
turned out to be false
that that's a reason for suspicion
it's probably a reason for suspicion
it doesn't mean that the things that
those that the people who told us
and were wrong or wrong about everything
it does mean that people particularly in
i this is my inference from that people
in a public setting should be more
humble about what they claim to know
particularly when it comes to public
health sure but i would say what we have
is a very powerful public health
apparatus that told us many things
essentially all of them turned out to be
false
you had a habit i can't that i can't
speak to you well yeah you can't but if
you looked at it you could you know
you're as capable as anyone of going
back to the history and looking at who
said what when and then seeing what
happened
right and if it is true that the
heterodox community of doctors and
scientists who were discussing this were
much more predictive than the public
health authorities and that in fact the
public health authorities
partnered with the uh social media
platforms and demonized the heterodox
scientists and doctors and in fact um
ruthlessly stigmatize them which goes on
to this day then that would tell you
something it's odd that the people who
had less predictive power were in a
position to destroy the careers of
people who were more predictive so you'd
have to yeah so what you'd have to do
correct what you'd have to do is you'd
have to break down those claims and see
which was true and that was false
absolutely
right well here's the problem nobody's
doing that but
somebody should right what this really
requires is a top-notch old-school
journalist to go back and say well
we're now years in let's figure out who
was right and let's figure out what
happened to them right i i hope that
happens that would seem to me to be most
most reasonable not only most reasonable
but incredibly pressing
yeah neil ferguson writes about that in
doom this idea that you you how do we
predict prevent the next pandemic you
know what do we do what kind of things
should we think about what kind of
infrastructure should we have
yeah yeah
so anyway um
let's put it this way
this we are not brand new to the
question of you know how to figure out
what's true right there are thousands of
years of track record on uh sorting out
claims and figuring out what's accurate
uh so i'm going to use that as a segue
into something that i'm doing
so when you talk about figuring out
what's true
i don't know
how much you listen to npr
npr npr well here let me tell you a
little something i don't know if anybody
yeah i can see you're sure yeah i
stopped i stopped uh donating to npr
asked me why yeah so here's my my
history i used to be uh as a
you know as a graduate student let's say
i was an npr addict enough so all of us
when i
when i went to panama to do my uh field
work yeah i was there for 18 months i
brought a shortwave radio with me
because sitting there in the canal zone
i was able to pick up npr and i listened
every day oh right so i was definitely
on board with npr and you know heather
and i look at each other sometimes now
and we say
was it this crazy then and i really
don't absolutely not i think
unquestionably not so what's happened to
it it's been ideologically
captured has become uh an ironic uh
inversion of itself yeah it's it is
really and for this so our show with
matt thornton our mutual friends all
things reconsidered he's by love thank
you i
came up with that in the shower uh he is
basically he's not only my jiu jitsu
teacher but when you talk about a
friendship of virtue he's someone with
whom i have a friendship of virtue
um so we're doing a show all things
reconsidered and we
so
the the show it's a five segment show
it's a five episode show of multiple
segments so the first segment
almost everybody i came up with this
idea because i was talking to a buddy of
mine
and he said yeah and i was telling him i
had this idea for a show about npr and
he said you know i stopped listening to
ann pierro when and i realized wow i bet
you so many people have stories of when
they stopped listening to npr so i just
started asking stories and we put it on
twitter hey do you have a story and we
just got inundated with i stopped
listening to npr when so
uh and if you haven't listened i've
listened to hundreds if not a thousand
hours of npr preparation for this and i
can tell you what i learned in a minute
but anyway so we do these i stopped
listening to npr when and then we have
episodes and matt and i analyze those
episodes and then we go into we have a
reverse pledge drive you know i pledge
not to
donate money to npr so unlike the
republicans who want nprd funded i don't
want nprd funded i think it's a terrible
idea
i want a station because i used to
listen to npr i used to not as
fanatically as you i loved npr i loved
you know the car talk was the only thing
i didn't like now really yeah the only
person yeah we'll get like ten thousand
emails you didn't like car talk you
bastard um
but i want a station everybody can
listen to that's not left that's not
right that's data driven all things
considered right right it presents facts
we just we just don't have that anymore
no and so so that's why i'm doing it
because i love npr not because i want to
throw kick them and have them be funded
but you know one thing i've learned from
this i've learned a lot from from
listening to
i don't even i truly don't even know how
many hours of npr and then analyzing
them with matt
if they have some if they'll have their
own expert on who's woke and i encourage
viewers to listen to if you can do the
brain damage i told my team this is the
hardest thing i ever had to ask of you
to take away some iq points but listen
to npr and you'll see this this runs
through all the episodes or virtually
all the episodes instead of
presenting an expert who actually
believes it on the other side
they will find somebody basically who's
woke or
forwards whatever narrative they're
trying to afford in the suite of
ideological propositions under the
rubric of critical race theory or
critical social justice or what have you
and and they'll say well well what is
what is an argument against that or what
does an expert say about that as opposed
to just finding someone who actually
believes it is a credible source and
asking them well what do you mean so
it's uh not a credible expert on the
other side
it's not a steel man it's like an actual
straw man argument correct incarnate and
it is fascinating to me to listen to
this and think about all those people
probably older people and i read
something a while ago the demographic of
people who listen to npr's by far and
away
they vote
and i'm thinking to myself wow all those
people who listen to npr
driving around
and they're
hearing caricatures of positions that
almost nobody believes right
it's become a
disinformation and i think most of those
people because we i've now talked to a
lot of them saying that by the way i
love this little this is a dark horse
thing
i love that fan sent us that i love that
yeah yeah um
yeah cool cool um
yeah they're driving on the scene i know
something's wrong i don't quite know
what it is but they they keep listening
to npr
right
and it it does have to do i mean i'm
sick of the term virtue signaling right
it's grown tired but it does have to do
with that in other words the fact that
you were in your car alone when you
didn't have to listening to npr is
somehow evidence that you are
you are virtuous and yeah so it becomes
that
that hallmark
um but
a do we have any idea what happened i
mean npr was always
liberal but i think it was liberal in
the positive sense of that term 30 years
ago and then it has become
you know it's the same blue it's the
same thing that's happened i i this is
simplistic but i'm going to put this out
as explanation it's the same thing with
everything else
people went to the academies
they studied the works of their
professor tested on things people just
the idea laundered they discharged their
moral impulses and journals it comes out
as knowledge they study that they get
correct answers they graduate four to
five six seven years they go into
positions of authority
they take all the insane nonsense that
they learn with them and that while the
missions like the aclu is completely
it's
ideologically captured to
use a phrase it keeps coming up the
southern poverty law center the missions
are the same but the people responsible
for discharging those missions are in
the orbit of the ideology and so they
don't
the aclu now is in no way what it was
when we were growing up so i mean you're
at the risk of
i'm risking serious cultural
insensitivity here because what it
sounds like
no i'm risking i'm risking a serious
error okay because what this evokes to
me is like a collegiate madrasa
right that's exactly what it is this is
an indoctrination
in a religious perspective and i don't
mean to denigrate all of the religious
perspectives that have you know gotten
people through
thousands of years by
guiding them right what i call uh
literally false metaphorical
metaphorically true beliefs
um but these are
basically brand new religions these are
cults and that cult the problem is it is
wielding a tremendous amount of power
and it is not only wielding a tremendous
amount of power which arguably is its
right in a democracy but it is wheeling
wielding that power against others
correct right we are not allowed to
believe that there are
uh two sexes and that you know
right their behavioral manifestation we
are not allowed to believe that we are
understood to be bad people if we do
yeah i i a little self-conscious about
saying this but i think that that uh my
former um um co-author and i were the
first people to come up with that idea
of vocalism as a religion in 2014 an
essay we published in all think uh
privileges the original sin we talked
about this is a new religion
but you see
so this is the explanatory mechanism for
why
media literally every institution you
can think of has been captured
well it's the mechanism by which it has
contaminated spread yes metastasize is
actually the exact right term it's not
contagion it's metastasized across the
body politic and
frankly this is uh maybe we will
talk a little bit about our mutual
friend james lindsay
but this is why i have a hard time
knowing what to think about where he is
which is that that metastasis is
as far as i can tell and you tell me if
you see it differently
it is capable of
destroying the west and it is not a
terrible stretch to imagine that it
jeopardizes our species in so doing
right the the the
yeah the world is depending on the west
to succeed oh i see you mean by species
yeah i don't think it's a species
threatening problem i think that there
are
too many prophylactics in place in other
countries to prevent that from
happening i don't know how you could
think that frankly because the problem
is there are too many industrial
processes on which we collectively
depend
that if we suddenly decide that
you know anybody who holds you know
anybody who subscribes to wrong think is
not entitled to work yeah that those
things will collapse yeah i i know i
don't believe that that that's tom
friedman's idea of the flat earth i
don't think that that's true it is
the idea that you know like that's why
they're in theory of the golden arches
for example no two countries have
ever had mcdonald's have gone to war
with themselves into yugoslavia there's
something about trade relations yeah i'm
not making that argument i'm making the
argument that there are technological
processes on which we depend
that require smart people to operate
them well drive all the smart people out
because they can't stand being forced to
say things they know are false yeah that
those systems will come apart and when
they do it is not just simply the
collapse of western nations but it is
those technological processes that we
are maintaining
and it is not yeah i'm not saying like
what swift banking systems or what are
you talking about about the nuclear
culture okay right the nuclear reactors
require us to maintain vigilance right
we have a problem
lasts for tens of thousands arguably
hundreds of thousands of years that we
have set in motion and we don't have a
mechanism for getting stupid people to
maintain it okay so let me throw this
out to you um
i can't believe i'm going to admit this
on your podcast but i'll admit this when
we first had this idea of of um wokism
as a religion
we tossed around the idea
of
infecting entire cultures with it
enemies of the united states north korea
iran i wouldn't put china as an enemy oh
you you were thinking of using it as an
offensive weapon yeah but we didn't know
how to deploy it right we just didn't
know how to deploy somebody experience
social justice yeah they did they did
they did beat us to it it's spread on
its own i
don't know i don't know that i don't
know how we rule out that this
the fact that we are attacking
everything that works yeah that we are
uninventing all of the things on which
the west is based correct
looks to me beyond what a pathology
right so let's i want you to repeat that
because that's so important we are what
did you say uninventing we are
uninventing all of the mechanisms in
which the west is based that is exactly
the issue
yep exactly right but the point the
point that i would make is
if we were neglecting
the things that allow the west to work i
could say okay that's
folly the fact that we are actively
going after everything that works
suggests enemy action now i don't know
oh it's our enemies oh okay so faisal
al-mutar uh
one very very very close friend of mine
he told me that the chinese government
and the russians i think he told me this
last year i didn't text him and ask him
at the end of the podcast we put in the
youtube description if you want uh and
uh qatar and oman etc
have
english language stations that push blm
crt etcetera to undermine the
foundations of our society i mean it's
brilliant you can do without throwing a
bomb you don't need to much like the old
star trek episode where the people walk
into the right yeah look it's um
people do not understand that culture is
as biological as genes
okay
right we see culture as an alternative
to biology but in fact culture is
biology and so
the selfish gene was great for that well
the self-esteem was not great it was the
it was the beginning of our ability to
rigorously understand that fact but it
could that's where i'm going with that
yes but continue your thought though so
here's the problem i want to give
dawkins his full do here because i think
that the selfish gene is the thing that
opens the door to our rigorously
understanding culture but it makes an
error a serious one but an error that i
can't fault dawkins for making anybody
who made as big a contribution as he did
would be liable to make an error
somewhere he made one
and it has not been corrected and as a
result we have the wrong understanding
of culture and the error
is that dawkins says culture is a new
primeval soup right that this is a new
evolutionary tree
he's not right about that
uh
it's been a while since i read the book
but
you're saying that
so i mean if you look at it with the
what is the advent of grain 10 000 years
ago and if you couple that with the
advent of language that would certainly
be new in terms of the broader
evolutionary landscape okay but
can we agree that the ability to
cultivate food
creates an opportunity to produce more
people who carry genes right correct is
that's physiological enough yeah the
point is when when dawkins
founds the idea of memes and memetic
evolution right he has exactly the right
idea but he understands it as
independent from genes and therefore he
imagines that a bunch of stuff which is
in conflict with the genes
evolves there and are you going to make
i'm just going to possibly preempt what
you're going to say you're going to make
the argument that
biological evolution
has certain built-in
advan at
that privileging or promoting certain
cultural practices
increases the likelihood
that the species
will
continue and thus there's some
covariance between
genetics and
cultural output you're working way too
hard oh okay you're working way too hard
what i'm saying is that cultural
evolution yeah is a means to an end
right the genes create a cultural mind
they create a brain that can be
inhabited by culture to solve a problem
the genes can't solve directly in the
same way
your dna
cannot cannot fly but dna can make wings
that allow a bird to fly and so my point
is yeah culture evolved to serve a
genetic purpose
i don't like the fact that it did but it
did so what do you mean by a cultural
mind
if you if you
were to pull a garter snake from your
garden okay and you were to
lecture it on epistemology
it would not work
right
that is true yeah the animal does not
have a mind that can take on that kind
of information and alter its behavior on
its basis okay okay
likewise a tree
an insect there are very few creatures
that have the capacity to alter their
way of thinking
as in
after they are uh
born in other words they're not
genetically pre-programmed
in a way that is productive
okay okay now
learning obviously exists but the point
is learning is not the same thing as
culture because culture is the
transmission between individuals of
useful information now the question is
is that
as dawkins presents it in the
self-stream in chapter 11. is that a new
evolutionary environment the same way if
i programmed a new biological
environment inside a computer we could
watch things evolve in their you know
game of life like
right is it a new environment yeah or
is it
the genes doing something that they
cannot do directly in an indirect form
why would you think the latter
because it can't be otherwise
okay imagine
look everything has a cost
the cost of religious belief yeah is
through the roof with respect to the
gene's perspective right imagine a book
full of things you're not allowed to do
genetically productive stuff you're not
allowed to rape you're not allowed to
steal you're not allowed to murder
you're not allowed to lie right those
are a lot of potentially valuable
strategies that have been taken off the
table by something that lives in culture
okay right
the only way that the genes would not
shut that [ __ ] down yeah is if that
stuff was more than paying for all of
the costs with benefits in the genes the
gene's eye view
right in other words
yeah that doesn't that assume that
that's the um
isn't that like a monolithic lens to
view the problem i mean it it could be
it could be that um that those
those things oh you're saying that
they're you're not saying they're
culturally adaptive then no i'm saying
they're culturally adapted but
culturally adaptive is not adaptive in
cultural terms they're saying in
biological terms i'm saying you're right
i'm saying the genes are in the drivers
so why can't why couldn't those things
be a byproduct like the moral mind why
couldn't that be a byproduct of an
evolutionary they're too useful
it's not a byproduct right you know but
you but it could it could be and it's a
what if it's an accident right and we
can make the same argument about a wing
or an i and the point is it's not a very
good
yeah that's the consensus from myers
saying yeah i mean
it's just logically a feeble argument
right the idea that we don't know that a
wing is an adaptation is a pretty weak
argument we can establish that it's an
adaptation by virtue of the fact that it
is expensive and it doesn't go away
that's also the creationist argument you
don't have half an eye etc
well you know but the bracket that
i mean you know nobody does a better job
with that argument than dawkins right
dawkins does a brilliant job of
cataloging all of the partial eyes that
exist in nature and you know the
creationists are of course wrong my
point is that dawkins was absolutely
right and revolutionary in what he said
but he has fallen short of maximizing
the return on what he spotted okay and
we started talking about this
because we're talking about woke stuff
right and so
the question is
wokism
is destructive of the fabric of the west
unquestionably
and
far
less in fact it's even intentionally
disruptive well that's what i'm arguing
right i'm not arguing that i know this
to be true but i'm already i'm arguing
that i know that to be true but we would
be crazy
not to wonder there look there are a lot
of people not to wonder why i finished
the sentence i told her what if our
antagonists in the world our competitors
we're not seeding this into our culture
oh yeah oh we're told there's no that's
what there's no question that they are i
mean
there is a question well i've seen some
of the shows the blm stuff coming out
but go ahead um if
the bolsheviks
introduce communism right
and i think oh
that's gonna that's gonna mess up the
russians and the russians are my
competitors so i'm going to you know i'm
going to add some communist propaganda
that's not me taking down russia correct
right that's me
amplifying correct the question is did
this woke revolution come from somewhere
did somebody have a meeting and say look
oh you're talking about the the genesis
beyond foucault dario leotard you're
talking about the way that was i'm
saying i don't want to assume that i
know why the west is deliberately it
would seem tearing apart every
functional structure and replacing it
with a fairy tale right but i don't know
if you think they're replacing it with
that's way too much what are they
replacing it with chass i mean what are
they replacing that's a fairy tale
that people in one but okay i'll guess
the idea that you can get rid of the
police and civilization will get better
is a fairy tale it's [ __ ] as fairy
tales tend to be
so my point is look
i don't know if wokism is
organic in its inception yeah and some
enemy said hey
look at this if we can get the west to
embrace this stuff we won't have to fire
a shot yeah that's
or it's possible that it came from some
enemy to begin with i don't know or
maybe it's impossible yeah i don't that
it's uh
i mean just look yeah it's how possible
i it's always possible
i know it's being funded by i don't want
to go so far as to say enemy regimes but
i guess in the case of of russia it is
an enemy regime
we know that this is being funded right
now i don't know in terms of your
comment about the genesis i don't really
know i mean it's an it's a built-in
divisive pitting people genders against
each other pitting races against each
other here's here's the unfortunate
problem yeah okay
religion is not a mind virus it's an
adaptation okay yeah you gave a great
lecture on my class about that so
i don't think this is logically in doubt
i think it's very difficult for people
to swallow because they for a long time
have been um
rewarded for simply pointing out the
folly of much of the analytical content
surrounding religion
but that's not really the point what
makes it an adaptation is the behavioral
prescriptions and those are not modern
those are behavioral prescriptions for a
world we don't live in anymore but
nonetheless the point is the
term mind virus
has been polluted by
the new atheists using it incorrectly
for things to which it doesn't apply
however
locism
is a mind virus right it will not
function as an adaptation what will
happen to it over time
just
well
totally total destruction it will
self-destruct it has to it
nothing else is possible because it has
no analytical content yeah not only that
so
let's delve into that if you don't want
to
i am
positive that this is a
i don't know when the expiration date is
every time i so so i've been screaming
about this since 2012. yeah um
[Music]
and it's
frankly it's very frustrating to me i
don't know when the expiration date is
um i see how quickly it's go so i used
to think okay
well it's in philosophy now
equity
you know hiring people just because they
have certain immutable physical
characteristics as thomas sewell said if
you want diversity and put some
republicans in the sociology department
um
so
i've watched this
contain i've watched this this
mine mine virus and i used to think okay
well they they just think philosophy is
not important and then it went from that
to medicine it went for i think it was
american airlines has diversity
requirements among pilots
like pilots holy [ __ ]
um and clearly nobody's gonna say that
those things aren't important
even if it won it would lose correct
because in the end that's abs that's a
great point if if if the coalition of
the woke
won all the power and had the ability to
architect the world that it claims it
wants a
it does not have enough competence to
make anything work but even more
troubling as peterson's talked about
that yeah is the fact that the various
different constituents of the coalition
would destroy each other right so it's
self unstable there's no question
there's there's no there there
right
so we know that
i don't think it matters when the only
question is are we going to let it go to
fruition or are we going to stop it
before it destroys everything in its
path which is what it's doing and that's
where we are right those of us who both
understand the problem with it and are
willing to say it out loud
and willing to
reap the consequences of that right and
you know they're arbitrary the thing
obviously detests us and you know
is a big part of that yeah um but that i
mean the process is worse than we know
yeah i mean at the risk of
uh
making things
difficult for us to parse
what i saw happen with standard
wokeness happened with covid too
i saw a coveted wokeness and i and
frankly i still see it right our entire
medical establishment
is pretending to know things that not
only does it not know but that aren't
true
and i don't know what you do when
suddenly all of your doctors are
persuaded of fiction or effectively
embracing
a cult and you know health is in the
balance i don't know what you do but
that's where we are
and that suggests something even more
frightening which is that the
disconnect between
um the minds of intelligent people and
reason
is potentially independent of topic
yeah that's what i think we came up with
that's the substitution hypothesis that
people just have to believe something
and then the brain is the hardware and
the content is just plugged in
well i don't think that that's generally
true but i think that the dysfunction
that we are seeing
is happening across domains and well
that's certainly
and the thing that spooks me the most is
that some of the people who i thought
were
most eloquent in spelling out what was
wrong with the original version of
wokeness missed the boat on covet
i don't know what to do with that people
who had the immunity
to woke thinking when the topic was
you know race and gender
didn't have what it took when it came to
so i feel viruses i feel the same way
about the new atheist and the skeptic
movement the same people who had the
tools
and it really is true that the tools are
the same you know what is your evidence
how do you weigh the evidence what is
the argument against it make it you can
do you know what tim van gelder does
argument mapping what have you
the tools are the same but
the the tremendous irony is that
from the skeptical movement and the
atheist movement
emerged new movements of people who
claim to be skeptics and atheists who
themselves were the most dogmatic
religious people you would ever meet
right like foot soldiers of these
movements that are not supposed to have
foot soldiers yes and then you know i
would point this out to folks and
i will say a difference is unlike
traditional religious people who say yes
i'm religious
wolf people won't say they're religious
they don't they haven't
it hasn't um
that idea
hasn't become
i don't know if acceptable or understood
or mainstream i don't know what the word
is but they won't say yes i'm religious
i'm i'm i'm the woke religion or the
critical social justice really i mean in
fact what they do is they claim the
mantle of science which is upside down
and back that's
yeah you know um and that's right so
yeah i i find that we are in the place
that we always end up when people uh
a viewer and my mindset on this get
together which is that we talk ourselves
blue in the face
trying to say look
this is not
difficult to understand no it's not
difficult to understand at all dangerous
it's frightening right but it's not hard
to see it the problem is that despite
the fact that it's not hard to see it
most do not
correct most do not and
most are
not only do most people not you know we
went around the country and then i got
to go for dinner pretty soon we we went
around the country and we did these
reverse q and a's and it's on my youtube
channel so what do you mean reverse q a
well instead of
uh the students asking the professor
questions and the professor answering i
asked students questions and they
answered and i asked it's street
epistemology asking people if their
confidence in their belief is justified
and we had like a like we had a likert
scale you know strongly agree agree
neutral but what have you they started
on the neutral i'd ask them a question
they'd go to one side and then i'd
ask them a question and encourage them
to move that's part of the solution to
this encourage people
that's the disposition again
changing your mind is a moral virtue
particularly if it's on the basis of
reason and evidence you change your mind
that's a good thing you should be
rewarded for that
and
among the things that i've learned from
that is that
so many of these young people
they're just it's not that they're
completely beholden to it but that they
accept
basic premises
of
the tenets of critical social justice
without ever giving it a thought without
even knowing what certain terms mean
they just accept it or they just they
just buy into it yeah i mean and you
know it's faith
yeah it's a type of faith it's a it's a
yeah it's a type of faith absent
metaphysics yeah yeah right it's it well
i mean
it's almost like
the um
the purest essence of faith right yeah
the deepest faith is the faith is based
on the least yeah and this is based on
nothing yeah kind of fetism of of yeah
it's true it is true
yeah yeah
all right well i feel like we've had
half a conversation maybe we should pick
it up it's good i appreciate it thank
you yeah uh thank you for stopping by
dark horse um
your new i guess it's not your new show
uh all things reconsidered it's going to
be on youtube we're shooting for october
to do that you can watch those sidewalk
exercises the street epistemology that
we've done there quite interesting oh
yeah and the youtube uh stations we have
so much content that that we're putting
on i have another book i'm going back to
hungary to
travel around and talk about scientific
skepticism and
wokism and what's your new book are you
ready to are you ready to say i can't
give the title yet still in work but
it's about a young socrates who wanders
a mythical greek uh countryside
fermenting a rebellion against the gods
having conversation he has a superpower
which is reason having conversations
with people different races and you know
mystical creatures
it hearkens back not to conservative
values but to ancient values discourse
dialectic socratic broadly socratic
values so i'm putting the final it's a
fiction book for children it's far more
difficult
it's a year overdue it's very very very
difficult to to my it's my first attempt
at fiction awesome well i'm looking
forward to thank you for reading that
okay well peter begosian it's been a
real pleasure thanks i appreciate it and
uh
thanks for joining us here on darkness
thanks everybody
you